lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
usar unos argumentos geométricos para
demostrar que las pendientes de líneas
perpendiculares son recíprocas y
negativas entre sí aquí tenemos las
líneas
lm que son perpendiculares se
intersectan con un ángulo recto ahora
vamos a poner algunas otras líneas aquí
que nos ayuden con nuestro argumento
geométrico vamos a dibujar una línea
horizontal que interese acá a estas
líneas en este punto de aquí y a este
punto le vamos a llamar punto a esta es
nuestra línea horizontal que sea
intersec aena y vamos a dibujar unas
líneas perpendiculares a esta línea que
acabamos de dibujar ponemos una línea
vertical aquí y ponemos otra línea
vertical acá
aquí tenemos 90 grados y aquí también
tenemos 90 grados esta línea de arriba
es horizontal y dibujamos dos líneas
verticales así que estos ángulos son
ángulos rectos y ahora vamos a definir
algunos puntos ya tenemos el punto a
aquí
este es el punto b este el punto c este
es el punto d y este es el punto
ahora pensemos en cuál será la pendiente
de la línea l vamos a mover un poco esto
la pendiente de l que va a ser podemos
ver a la línea l como la línea que
conecta a los puntos c ya así que
podemos decir que la pendiente de l
también es la pendiente del segmento c a
l es la línea sea para encontrar la
pendiente tenemos que calcular el cambio
en g y dividirlo entre el cambio en x
nuestro cambio en que va a ser se ve la
longitud del segmento c b
este es nuestro cambio en g se ve entre
nuestro cambio en x que es la longitud
del segmento b
/ b y ahora cuál es la pendiente de la
línea m la pendiente de m o también
podemos decir que es la pendiente de la
línea a e y la pendiente del segmento a
y nuevamente va a ser el cambio en g
entre el cambio en x el cambio en y va a
ser
vamos a ir desde aquí desde este nivel
desde el punto de hacia abajo hasta el
punto e también lo pudimos haber
dibujado en este lado de la aee es
nuestro cambio en ye y podríamos
sentirnos tentados a decir bueno este es
el cambio en la longitud del segmento d
pero recuerden que esta ya se está de
crem entando así que vamos a restar esta
longitud ya que pasamos de este nivel de
y hacia este otro nivel de iu y cuál es
nuestro cambio en x pues conforme
pasamos de aaee nuestro cambio en x va a
ser la longitud
segmento d así que la pendiente de m va
a ser menos d
/ a d va a ser menos d es menos porque
estamos bajando el nivel en y entre el
segmento ade y quizá alguno de ustedes
ya está inspirado con lo que ya
escribimos porque ahora sólo tenemos que
establecer que estos dos triángulos el
triángulo cb
y el triángulo ade son semejantes y
después podremos demostrar que estos son
los recíprocos negativos de sus
pendientes así que vamos a demostrar que
estos triángulos son semejantes ahora
digamos que tenemos este ángulo aquí
cuya medida es x y digamos que aquí
tenemos otro ángulo que mide ya sabemos
que x + más 90 tiene que ser igual a 180
porque juntos son ángulos suplementarios
así que puedo escribir que x más 90 más
va a ser igual a 180 grados podemos
restar 90 en ambos lados y nos queda que
x + es igual a 90
estos son enunciados algebraica mente
equivalentes y cómo podemos usar esto
para encontrar los otros ángulos en
estos triángulos pues digamos que x más
este ángulo aquí abajo tiene que ser
igual a 90 grados o podemos decir que x
más 90 más algo más tiene que ser igual
a 180 grados
aquí estamos analizando el triángulo cb
y la suma de los ángulos internos en
cualquier triángulo siempre nos va a dar
180 grados
así que x más 90 más que va a ser igual
a 180 grados pues x más 90 más ya
habíamos establecido esto aquí de forma
similar aquí
90 más algo más tiene que ser igual a
180 grados usamos el mismo argumento ya
sabemos que más 90 más x nos da 180
grados y noten que ya establecimos que
el triángulo abc es semejante al
triángulo ade
ya que sus correspondientes ángulos
internos son iguales ambos triángulos
tienen un ángulo x un ángulo iu y el
ángulo de 90 grados son triángulos
rectángulos así que por ángulo ángulo
ángulo uno de nuestros postulados de
semejanza
sabemos que el triángulo de a es
semejante al triángulo a b c y esto nos
dice que la proporción de los lados
correspondientes en ambos triángulos
será la misma así que vamos a encontrar
la proporción de los lados
correspondientes nosotros sabemos que la
proporción de seve entre b
va a ser igual al lado correspondiente
de cb es el lado opuesto al ángulo x así
que el lado correspondiente acb es el
lado ade así que esto es igual a ave
entre cuál es el lado correspondiente a
vea vea es el lado opuesto al ángulo y
así que en este otro triángulo el lado
opuesto allí es el lado del ave entre de
y esto de acá
vimos al principio que es la pendiente
del segmento l esto es la pendiente de l
y cómo se relaciona esto con la
pendiente de m noten que la pendiente de
m es el recíproco de esto ya que tenemos
a d / d
y además tenemos este negativo de aquí
así que esto es el recíproco negativo de
la pendiente de m
y aquí está acabamos de demostrar que si
suponemos que m y l son perpendiculares
y establecemos estos triángulos
semejantes podemos mostrar que la
pendiente de él es el recíproco negativo
de la pendiente de m